أشعر أن هذه المجموعة مملوكة
للعامة وأعتبر نفسي
حارسًا للمجموعة ولذلك من
المهم بالنسبة لي أن أستمر في مشاركة
هذه المجموعة مع الجمهور وأنا
فخور جدًا لأنك ترى في هذه الغرفة
بعضًا من أهمها  أسماء
فناني القرن العشرين من الذكور والإناث الذين كانوا
نشطين في المنطقة وخارجها، لقد كنت
متعمدًا للغاية في ضمان أن يكون هذا
معرضًا للتوازن بين الجنسين فقط
لشرح سبب أهمية
إظهار أن النساء كن نشطات أيضًا في
منتصف القرن العشرين و  لقد كانوا
نشطين في العديد من أشكال
المواد المختلفة للفنانين مثل استخدام
الباتيك واستخدام النحاس واستخدام
الأواني الزجاجية الخزفية والنسيج وهنا
ترى النحت
أشعر أن
عدم التوازن بين الجنسين في المتحف الغربي هو
بالتأكيد شيء يجب علينا القيام به  لا
يمكن تقليدها في أجزاء أخرى من العالم
واعتقدت أن لدي الفرصة
لاتخاذ خطوة جذرية وعدم قول المزيد من
الآن فصاعدًا، سنعرض فقط التوازن بين الجنسين
في معارضنا، هذه
المجموعة هنا بالتأكيد لها
سرد اجتماعي وسياسي  فقط اشرح لذلك
هناك عدة أنواع من الفن السياسي
هناك أعمال فنية أنشأها فنانون
كانوا فنانين سياسيين مثل من
يظهر خلفك في هذه اللقطة مع
فنانة مصرية مجردة نشطة منذ
الثلاثينيات وبيكي استضافتها في
منزلها تجمعات فنية  ومجموعة الحرية
في مصر، وهي
مجموعة يسارية متطرفة دافعت عن الفنانين
في أوروبا في ذروة
القمع النازي للفنانين قبل الحرب العالمية
الثانية، ومن ناحية أخرى، لديك فنانين
ابتكروا صورًا سياسية في
أعمالهم مثل ليلان سير من  سوريا
وغيرها الكثير على سبيل المثال فلسطين
والعديد من النساء الأخريات على مدار
النصف الثاني من القرن العشرين
يصورن الأحداث السياسية التي
حدثت في المنطقة من خلال
موادهن وأه مبيعات إبداعاتهن في الشرق الأوسط
لم تتضاءل أثناء
الوباء  لكن الاهتمام لا يزال مرتفعًا بين
هواة الجمع، ما هو شكل السوق بالنسبة للاهتمام
بفنون الشرق الأوسط في
الوقت الحالي، حسنًا، السوق
رائع للغاية لأن لديك
أرقامًا قياسية عالمية يسجلها
فنانون معاصرون، لديك أعمال تتراوح قيمتها بين مليون ومليوني
دولار، إنها
لا زلت لا تصل إلى عشرات الملايين من الدولارات
التي حصلت عليها مع بعض الفنانين الغربيين وحتى
بعض الفنانين الآسيويين على مدار العقد الماضي
أو نحو ذلك
أه ولكن بالنسبة للشرق الأوسط، فأنا
سعيد جدًا برؤية الفنانين المعاصرين أه يحققون
أرقامًا قياسية ولذا أعتقد أن هذا  هو
انعكاس للاهتمام العالمي
بفن الشرق الأوسط، وأعتقد أيضًا أنه بمثابة
إشارة إلى الفنانين الشباب بيكي بأنهم
يستطيعون كسب عيشهم من خلال
خلق الفن الذي تتحدث عنه،
باستخدام معرض مثل هذا
للتغلب على المفاهيم الخاطئة أو
المفاهيم الخاطئة حول  عن أه
المناطق أه ماذا تقصد بذلك ما
هي سوء الفهم ماذا
تفعل من خلال هذا المعرض لمعالجة
هؤلاء هناك الكثير من
المفاهيم الخاطئة حول مثلا
حقوق الأقليات في المنطقة
تاريخيا ولهذا نؤكد
على سبيل المثال  حول الأقليات الدينية في
جميع معارضنا، نعرض أعمال
الأقلية المسيحية في العالم العربي
والأقلية البهائية والعالم العربي
الأقلية اليهودية لدينا أعمال فنية
لفنانين يهوديين من الذكور والإناث
في هذا المعرض يقولون الأقليات الجنسية الأقليات
العرقية  من المهم جدًا
أن تكون هذه رؤية شاملة
للمنطقة لأنه عندما أنظر إلى
تاريخ العالم العربي أرى أننا
فعلنا الكثير من الأشياء الجيدة في
القرن العشرين ولكننا ارتكبنا الكثير من الأخطاء
أيضًا، لذا للمضي قدمًا  كيف يمكننا أن نعكس
الطبيعة الكوزموبوليتانية للعالم العربي
في منتصف القرن العشرين والتي
ضمت كل هذه الأقليات المتنوعة
والمجموعات المتنوعة، بينما نعمل على تصحيح
وتصحيح الأخطاء التي
ربما ارتكبتها الأغلبية تجاه هذه
الأقليات